joining me now for reaction is
Republican congressman mark meadows
who's the chairman of the house freedom
caucus and representative Raja
Krishnamoorthy who's a Democrat from
Illinois it's great to see both of you
let's let's start with you congressman
meadows I just delivered some some tough
medicine maybe it was too tough maybe it
was too harsh but you know that's just
that's what's what I'm gonna do well
when I look at this legislation I like
call it legislation it's more than a
thousand there here there it is I think
this is not draining the swamp it who's
actually reading this congressman who
has read this entire bill tonight I can
tell you no one's read the entire bill
some two thousand two hundred and thirty
two pages that we just got a little over
an hour ago I'm about two hundred pages
into it obviously we have staff going
through it but really this is not about
draining the swamp and when you look at
this particular bill were you too harsh
no the answer is no you could have been
a lot harsher I mean we've continued to
fund the sanctuary cities we continue to
fund Planned Parenthood we don't build
the wall but yet we put money in for a
tunnel the last time I checked when the
president was campaigning he wasn't
campaigning for a tunnel between New
Jersey and New York he was campaigning
about a border wall on our southern
border and so you know there's a lot to
be disappointed we're still going
through this but I'm not very optimistic
that there will be conservative wins in
this congressman Krishnamoorthy
if I'm a Democrat and I see the house is
in Republican hands the Senate's in
Republican hands we have a Republican a
conservative populist Republican like
Donald Trump in the White House and I
see Planned Parenthood funded sanctuary
cities funded Chuck Schumer gets his his
mega tunnel of New Jersey New York and a
bunch of other stuff gets funded there's
not a lot to be upset about really in
this budget all things considered your
reaction well look I think that the
president's supportive on a lot of
shared priorities it fully funds
military and domestic programs
additional funding for the opioid crisis
which is just ravaging our district and
then it helps to increase funding for
NIH as well as making sure our veterans
are taken care of
I think I
haven't read the whole bill as Mark
mention but I I'm optimistic I'm hopeful
that we can come to a compromise by
tomorrow now you haven't read the bill
and I'm not criticizing you because
there's no one it mean the Evelyn would
a plus citation student couldn't read
this okay so I'm not criticizing you
because you just got this now given what
we know about our current debt levels
are it's exploding exploded under the
President Obama exploded under bush and
now it's set to increase by you know
could be increased by another trillion
dollars mark tell me if I'm wrong about
this under the under what we're looking
at tonight don't you rehab don't go
don't we have a moral obligation to be
honest with the American public about
where we're getting is the money to fund
all these important priorities China
Japan Germany all the people were
borrowing it from and all the printing
we're gonna have to do because we don't
got we don't have this money do it well
we don't in Laura here's one of the
interesting things yes we'll end up with
a trillion dollar deficit probably that
will come out in October of this year
trillion dollars plus but here's the
other interesting thing you don't have
to read the fine print to understand
that we're going to grow the size of
government by 12 to 13 percent so when
you're looking at that kind of growth I
don't know that his district or my
district anybody back home saw a 13%
increase in their wages but yet we're
somehow going to give government or
raise like that here's the other problem
Laura is this we have a
republican-controlled house we have a
republican-controlled Senate and we have
a Republican in the White House and we
have a Democrat here tonight saying how
great this bill is there is a problem
there when you have that well I think
that I think the right honourable
gentleman from North Carolina first of
all I already like you because you came
on the show a lot of your colleagues
Walt but I already like you because
you're being honest like you have to be
this is a good bill for Democrats it's
good the military gets tons of funding
and that's that's all great military
needs it raise I understand that but
you're smiling it's not just because
you're hanging out with us on it on a
whatever the heck this is Wednesday
night look you're having fun this is a
good deal for Democrats
how can you not smile when you see a
staccato look the bottom line is this is
I think look I haven't read the full
bill I haven't made my final decision on
this but if it fully funds military
programs right now our military
readiness is at all-time lows general
mattis I'm sorry secretary Madison said
we can't go on and yet another
continuing resolution a stopgap budget
it would hurt the military if for know
about that our troops to some
godforsaken country right maybe I mean
maybe we should think about what it's
gonna cost before we like submit our
troops again to another multiple
deployment you know intervention I mean
yes oh well good now to say like we're
in the hole like five trillion dollars
but right and here's the other thing is
if we wanted to fund the military why
didn't we just put forth the funds to
fund the military and deal with the
non-defense discretionary separate but
somehow we put them together so that we
gather the size of government that's the
prop well I think we got to take care of
the veterans we got raise an issue about
the bill people say we got to take care
of the veterans okay that's just I
understand that but we also have other
issues that are weighing down on the
American public and I and I do believe
tonight the American people have to
understand this we're gonna have you
know 438 congressmen got a hundred
senators gonna vote on this legislation
and the next what 72 hours guys 72 hours
something like be quicker than that okay
48 hours and I would say 98% of them and
I'm being charitable will not have read
this and we're gonna have to pass it to
see what's in it
we're back in that stage and I know
there's good stuff people will get some
help but this can't we've got to go back
to the regular order where each
department with you each department gets
a budget and and each budget is voted on
we can have some transparency and maybe
it's maybe it's this long maybe it's
this long not really thing speak Ryan
I'm really disappointed that speaker
Ryan didn't present it was presented
with a budget this this particular bill
sooner than tonight we need regular
order around here so that I'm
rank-and-file I'm not leadership I got I
don't
I don't I can't I don't run the trains
around here all I can say is I need more
time to read through this thing I'd like
to work with people like congressman
meadows and make it a better bill but if
the choice is not funding the troops not
taking our veterans nothing but they're
in shutdown all right I can't do that
congressman they're putting you in that
position and it's in it's with the way
Washington works like you got to do what
you got to do it you got to pass it
because otherwise the troops aren't
gonna get you know it's just ridiculous
you cannot I mean we cannot do this to
the American taxpayers and our future
generations but congressman meadows
congressman Christian birthday it's
great to have you both on fan cheffy
with you fantastic segment and it's it's
complicated so we really appreciate it